when I was 13 years old I read the
Batman comic book The Dark Knight
Returns by Frank Miller it quite blew my
burgeoning adolescent mind and opened up
my sensibilities to storytelling in ways
that I had not yet foreseen and then
following that experience I was hooked
on Batman until the end of my teenage
years at least I had even drawn a giant
Batman on my bedroom wall at the age of
15 I see now that my attraction to that
character would be part of forming my
understanding of visual storytelling
through the medium of comics but most of
all it forged some of my symbolic
understanding of the of the dynamics of
the periphery of the edge and how its
different elements fit together now
after years of meditating not on comics
but on patterns in the Bible and in
other stories I'm quite happy to revisit
the hero of my teenage years and show
all of you just how closely the story of
Batman maps on to the biblical story of
the fall of Adam and Eve
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world
the origin story in Batman follows very
well the origin story in the Bible so
before we get to the bat I need to lay
out the first story Adam and Eve are
naked in the garden their innocence in
their nakedness is in a way a form of
completeness and the Garden of Eden is a
place which is safe from death and the
hostility of the world they're tempted
by snake to eat the fruit of none of the
knowledge of good and evil and so they
come to know the opposition of good and
evil they enter a world of duality and
conflict which tends towards
fragmentation and corruption this
corruption which is death itself in the
moment of the fall they also notice that
they're naked and so they desire to
cover themselves now noticing what is
naked is seeing one's own vulnerability
realizing that one is in danger and
therefore making us want to cover
ourselves but this can be seen in a more
encompassing light as realizing our own
insufficiency and therefore a need to
add to ourselves supplement our
insufficiency in order to stave off
death in the Bible this is represented
by several things first it's this
insufficiency is compensated for by work
God tells Adam to work the ground to
keep death at bay
second it is represented by clothing
which is the most immediate image of the
supplement adding a layer of protection
around you and in the Bible this is
represented as a tough layer of animal
skins the image must be understood as
using these dead animal skins against
death so putting on a layer of death to
fight off death somewhat like a vaccine
is made of the disease or an antidote is
made from the poison which is there to
which it is meant to protect you from
the last example of this process of
supplement begun as a reaction to the
fall and its consequences is of course
technology in the genealogy of the fall
we can see the descendants of Cain
developing two
ecology cities metallurgy weapons all in
an attempt to protect themselves but
ultimately to fight within a world of
increasing corruption and increasing
duality that is the origin story in the
Bible in Batman the origin story lays
itself out almost perfectly on to that
pattern Bruce Wayne a young boy is with
his father and mother walking out of a
show or a movie they're content they are
complete they are innocent of the
possible danger around them they are
also rich which is important an
important symbol for their sense of
sufficiency in that way they are unaware
of their nakedness they are unaware of
their vulnerability so they move out
into an alley and an alley is like a
snake okay I bet you didn't expect that
comparison one of the important aspects
of the serpent is that it is an image of
chaos and the undefined because it
twists and it turns from left to right
like the shifty slithering creature an
alley is the strange space created by
the inevitable area between tall
buildings I mean although it can somehow
function as a street it's not fully a
street or a park or or or on like other
official public spaces in the end an
alley is the side effect of a city we
could say so it's normal that we tend to
associate alleys with illicit activity
like prostitution crime drug use
homelessness and and everything else so
the sense of sufficiency of the Wayne
family is inappropriate they should not
have gone so brazenly into a crime
ridden space so to in the act of eating
the fruit of the tree in order to be
like God Adam and Eve exhibit a sense of
false self-sufficiency which will
finally turn upside down into a
consciousness of what they lack that is
realizing they're naked so the family
moves innocently into this alley and
they're confronted with the duality of
good and evil
Joy's a criminal tries to rob and in the
robbery kills Bruce Wayne's parents
Bruce cannot do anything to stop the
death of his parents by standing there
helpless facing their murder his
nakedness is exposed he realizes his
insufficiency he's ashamed and he feels
guilty for not being able to save his
parents his confrontation with evil
becomes also his own original sin that
is that which he will spend the rest of
his life trying to compensate for so how
does Bruce Wayne compensate for this
initial moment of loss the first thing
he does is fully inhabit the mode of
duality there is corruption there is
evil there are criminals and he will
fight them but in order to do that he
must supplement his nakedness like Adam
he must work and Bruce's work takes the
form of training now the second thing
Bruce does is put on a garment of animal
skins now if in the tradition this
notion of the garment of dead animal
skins is meant to represent this layer
of death of animality and this
coarseness to protect ourselves from
death so - Batman chooses the imagery of
the bat for all its dark implications he
uses darkness against darkness turns the
fear that he felt in his childhood
tragedy against the criminals who had
caused him fear blood fetch
that's right in me
this time I only shared my dread and
using the imagery of the bat Batman also
participates in the aesthetic of the
gargoyle those dark monstrous protectors
on the outside of buildings which are
the architectural version of these
garments of skin if in the story of Adam
the hiding of nakedness is very direct
here the hiding of nake nakedness
happens more subtly Bruce could not
defend his parents he was exposed as
incapable and naked and so Batman
effectively hides Bruce Wayne under a
veil of Darkness hides the person who
was shown to be insufficient by putting
on a mask and a persona by changing even
his name of course we cannot fail to see
how we often do this in everyday life we
hide our weaknesses and insufficiency
and even our sins under some forced
virtue some excessive humor some
constant defines or any other
psychological mask that we can put on
Batman also accumulates advanced
technology all these amazing vehicles
and weapons not to speak of his bat
computer this is in line with the notion
of technology as a version of this
supplement which we saw in the lineage
of Kane who built cities and ultimately
weapons of war all of these are like
extra layers of protection put on by
Batman to fight criminals and corruption
and if you're not yet convinced added to
all this are also some extra biblical
traditions which actually show Adam and
Eve living in a cave under the mountain
of Paradise after the fall living in a
cave is a primordial example of using
the dark covering of earth itself as a
kind of shield to hide and protect
oneself from the hostile outside and so
too Batman has a bat cave under his
original Eden under the estate of the
family which he has lost
and this cave acts as a dark covering
for his own war on crime now what is
interesting and this is the case of many
other stories as well is that when we
look at the elements of Batman his name
his costume the training the technology
the Batcave one might not see
immediately how all these elements
naturally fit together in such a
satisfying manner but once we have seen
them through this more primordial lens
can easily understand why Batman has
become one of the most iconic characters
of the late 20th and early 20th century
but Dark Knight if you enjoyed this
content and our exploration of symbolism
get involved I love to read your
insights and questions in the comments
section you can also share this video on
social media to your friends and as you
can please consider supporting us
financially through patreon or PayPal
you'll find those links in the
description below